let's begin this hour with the latest on
the midterms and where we stand right
now with five Senate races still to call
it's still a toss-up over who will
control chant the chamber one of those
races Georgia may go to a runoff in
December the house is leaning Republican
but it's nowhere near the red wave that
many analysts were expecting we know
whoever has the majority it will be a
narrow one so one reason Republicans are
not celebrating Nationwide is this
result in Pennsylvania Democratic
Lieutenant Governor John Federman beat
Dr mehmed Oz to flip that seat blue
Sharika Duncan is in Pittsburgh jarika
good morning
good morning and when you think about
the amount of money spent and Those ads
you could almost call this race a slug
Fest of sorts last night we were at
fetterman's Campaign Headquarters as he
celebrated that victory over Mehmet Oz
but the question really is how did we
get here so we took a look at some of
the polls coming in and we want to share
that information with you when you look
at the gender gap for instance between
the voters women in the Keystone State
back fetterman over Oz by 15 points
while men supported us by 13 points and
it looks like concerns over abortion
rights played a major role this is one
of the only states where abortion was
more important to voters than inflation
something else worth noting that was
interesting that happened here yesterday
in Luzerne County made up of about 200
000 registered voters and went to Trump
in 2020 well the county ran out of paper
ballots precincts were ordered to stay
open until 10 pm versus closing at 8pm
as of this morning though the problem
seems to have been remedied with a
majority of votes now counted but
lawsuits are still ongoing in the fight
over mail-in ballots after the state
Supreme Court ruled that undated or
incorrectly dated ballots would not be
counted but even if those votes are
counted in the end they're likely to
Favor John fetterman we have not heard
from the Oz campaign but it appears that
two big state races were won by
democrats that would be governor-elect
Josh Shapiro and U.S senator elect John
fetterman Gail
tarika Duncan thank you very much